make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking back up with the
conclusion of Ultron forever and the
Ultron forever story again this is this
is this is the the kit and kaboodle the
whole end of it all with dr. doom having
seemingly taken over everything right
really kind of taken over where we're
all Tron left off and again that's one
of the things that we hit at in the last
video is that for Doctor Doom this makes
sense it's what his character does
either he outright goes out there and
tries to seize power or he's an
opportunist
right he waits until the right
opportunity arises and then he leaps on
it and then tries to seize control but
whatever the case is in this instance
because of the fact that Ultron himself
has basically been destroyed
this left a kind of vacuum there right
like the Ultron robot factories are
still cranking away the bio slaves you
know former humans are still there
there's just nobody controlling them and
so dr. doom used that moment to seize
control of all those systems and now dr.
doom runs everything and so with that
being the case he's come to the
realization that as it stands right now
Asgard is the one place whereby he's not
really operating or at least he he
doesn't mean he has a presence there
Ultron used that as a base of operations
but at the moment that's where the
heroes are located at this were they
kind of teleported to and so the
discussion they sort of have there is
okay well let's break this down and
let's see you know how it is that we can
we can find some way to confront Doctor
Doom or some way to defeat Doctor Doom
now the other part of this is that
vision makes the case well let me talk
to them right now let me talk to dr.
doom and let's see if we can't figure
out what's going on but he's almost kind
of dismissed and a lot of people are
asking questions about whether or not
he's been compromised whether or not
he's somebody they can actually work for
the team because remember this is vision
and a lot of these other Avengers are
currently out of time and in their time
stream they come from a point where
vision was created by Ultron right he
hasn't quite turned to become a
superhero yet and so because of that it
creates a situation where it's kind of
like okay kid we really trust these guys
and you know he really trusts vision and
even if he is a good guy now
is there some kind of subroutine that's
allowing you know Ultron or at least you
know that kind of it was activated when
he came here and now doctor dooms
controlling him is everything sorted out
right is he really a good guy those are
the kind of questions that people are
asking now the other part of this are
all of the all the Asgardians themselves
and when I say all the Asgardians I do
mean like all the Asgardians right like
hella SIF the Warriors 3 like all the
different trolls and so on and so forth
all these as Guardians that exist out
there are all trapped in what's kind of
referred to as a mirror prison and the
reason why it's called that is because
everything is the opposite right so
whenever you speak to them
here your words backwards right they
hear it all kind of garbled and jumbled
and they can't really make out what it
is at your sink and so that's one of the
things that kind of makes it impossible
because the other part of this is the
mirror dimension kind of you know begins
to sort of SAP them of their power and
of their magic right so they don't
really have the ability to break free
and they're just constantly just sort of
wasting away until there really doesn't
seem to be anything left the problem
with this is that the powers of Thor and
the shield of Captain America haven't
really been able to break through this
thing so there's no real conceivable
means Aveeno to penetrate this prison of
sorts until you get to James Road right
and James rose canisters poking around
and doing a little bit of Investigation
now what this also leads to is Captain
America and the rest of the Avengers
showing up here and battling a whole
bunch of these Doombot ships right
attacking these ships basically
destroying the doombots that are
contained inside and kind of calling it
a day right and for the most part you
end up having it happen in America who
successfully come into yours a ship
fires on another ship that's sort of a
thing the problem here is that these are
carrier vessels right these are vessels
designed to carry a whole bunch of
doombots from one location to the next
they're really kind of battle cruisers
right they're big they're clunky they're
not like super lightweight and agile
ships and so because of that they kind
of move like a bus you know we're like a
semi truck and so at that point it's a
big clunky vessel and it's not really
doing her any good so as a result of
that you end up having all the Thor's
who throw their hammers to take out one
of the ships that starts firing on
Captain America's vessel and then of
course Captain America you know ends up
retaliating as well and and so on but if
I kind of goes away you would expect it
to but the important thing and really
wanted big takeaways that comes from
this is James Rhodes now an important
thing to understand here is James Rhodes
was never really like a poor man's Tony
Stark he was a substitute Tony Stark for
a time but James Rhodes was one of these
characters where he wasn't really like
the the kind of genius that Tony Stark
was right it made sense what game Rhodes
was not designed to be the kind of
genius a Tony was he was designed to be
a different version of Iron Man right a
different take on the character insofar
that Tony Stark was there was a
prodigious engineer James Rose was
actually in a lot of ways a more
honorable man but also an exceedingly
good pilot he was a cunning pilot and a
great friend I know that because I
watched him burn alive on the lava flow
and it was it was messed up you know but
like he was a good friend that's what
friends do to friends we let them we
chop off their limbs and let them burn
alive in a lava flow
ob1 was a dick like it's just that's
just the way it is anyway the benefit of
James Rhodes come
in a play that he's not like the kind of
engineer that Tony is he still is pretty
smart and one of the things that he
starts to pick up on here is that with
regards to the prison that light can
pass through right he can see them they
can see him which means that this
barrier is essentially transparent right
that's the way light works everything
that you see is there as a result of
light reflecting off of it right so if
this dome was designed in such a way to
where he couldn't see anybody on the
other side well then of course it is
reflecting light light cannot pass
through but because light can pass
through this this dome then it means
other forms of light like a high
intensity laser can pass through as well
and that was kind of the failing of the
various Thor's albeit they didn't really
have the wherewithal to understand
engineering on that scale and this thing
was built long after Tony Stark and
those Reed Richards and those guys have
been destroyed so there's really nobody
there to like inform them you know how
to do that but James Rhodes basically
uses the repulsor rays along with high
intensity lasers and basically you know
along with the help of beta ray bill on
the other side shatters the entire
prison right which frees all of the
Asgardians who were there it's a cool
moment right it's a cool little homage
to James Rhodes that even back then
during the during the early days when he
was playing his role as Iron Man for for
a time that he was an exceedingly
capable character and so what this does
is it picks up with vision jumping on
board the ship that's currently being
piloted by Captain America and basically
crashing the ship of course you can
adjust as density so visions gonna be
fun and the day kind of seems to be
saved right like all these doom bots
that were showing up on the doorstep of
ask of Asgard have basically been
destroyed the perception was the day was
saved but as soon as they turn around
there's even more and that really was
the nature of Ultron and that's really
what you kind of ran into when it came
to any kind of technological singularity
and Marvel Comics sentinels Ultron
doombots whatever the case is that what
you ran into you was essentially a war
of attrition in the sense that like the
heroes would just be worn down by a
constant overwhelming force right that's
why when you had things like Days of
Future past you look at the list of
heroes who died in the Incredible Hulk
is there and the question is how could
the Incredible Hulk fall to sentinels he
would tear them apart
well because it's an overwhelming number
of signals and that overwhelming number
stays replenished right so maybe it was
something like 300 sentinels descended
on the Incredible Hulk and he was just
fighting for days and then eventually
the Incredible Hulk wore out and that's
when the Sentinels killed him that's
kind of how this this war of attrition
works for the Ultron robots is the exact
same way with the doombots is the exact
same way the person ER or the side with
the most resources will take out the
side with
resources right it doesn't matter how
badly you want that battle it's just the
way that it works right it's just the
way this goes down and so because that
you end up having all these different
superheroes you know and it's kind of
cool to see right all the Asgardians all
the superheroes all these forces
basically going against all these doom
bots and holding their own fight readily
right I mean just holding their own able
to able to destroy a whole host of them
but then you start to see small things
right you see James Rhodes talking about
how his suit is down to 15% there's a
statement of how long have we been doing
this you essentially have all these guys
who have been fighting me over for a
long long time and so ultimately you end
up having a retreat that's called
between Captain America and and Black
Widow in vision and they start talking
about how like their numbers aren't
really wearing thin but their energy is
they're starting to be worn down this
battle is gonna result in them losing if
it keeps on going on for too long
and that's when vision chimes in and
says okay did it's time that you guys
trusted me right like I'm an Avenger I
promise you I'm an Avenger I'm one of
the good guys trust me here and
everything will be fine and so
ultimately they do what they end up
doing is teleporting directly to where
Doctor Doom is and that's when vision
starts talking to him and saying look
for the Avengers we're not surrendering
like we're not giving up it's just
important that we have we sit down and
have a civilized conversation and then
he calls him Doombot and that's what we
end up learning here
this was never Doctor Doom in the first
place this was a Doombot the entire time
specifically it was a character named
Doombot now the question is who is Dumba
or in Marvel Comics and 2013 as part of
these second or third wave of Marvel now
you ended up getting a Sam Humphreys
line of comics called Avengers AI now it
only lasted 12 issues but it was
basically a an Avengers team composed of
artificially intelligent beings right so
like vision and so on and so forth what
you also had is you had a new character
introduced as Doombot who is basically a
Doombot who kind of become autonomous or
self-aware now he may have predated
Avengers AI and in fact I think he
actually did but this is basically what
this characters turn into this is what
this guy's evolved into that following
the the death of Doctor Doom you know
during the the rise of Ultron and the
destruction of all the superheroes that
this Doombot was the last surviving
version and so what enough happening was
a kind of protocol was enacted where
doctor dooms idea that he must always
live basically kind of activated a
subroutine that essentially turned this
Doombot into Doctor Doom I convinced him
that he's Doctor Doom and then you get
this kind of weird exchange are you
truly Doctor Doom because dr. doom would
not take instruction from anybody like
that he would never let another dictate
his actions right so it's like I don't
let any
tell me what to do even myself like
that's kind of what visions
communicating here which is kind of
nonsensical doesn't really seem to make
any sense but ultimately it kind of
leads to to this Doombot basically
saying okay you know I am my own person
right like I'm my own individual I am
absolutely control yes I was created by
a Victor Von Doom but I am NOT Victor
Von Doom I am my own person and that
kind of makes sense because Doombot was
a hero he seemingly just kind of lost
himself in the programming that was that
was activated following the death of the
original Doctor Doom and so what you end
up getting here is kind of a stand down
where doombots forces end up backing
down they end up stopping everything
comes to a head everything sort of ends
and what he does is it kind of releases
all of his doombots as well as all of
humanity to kind of go forward and live
their lives as they would see fit now
none of this really ends up mattering in
that and you know in the end anyway
because from what we saw in Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers the New Avengers
everybody on earth just ends up getting
turned into a giant artificial
intelligence anyway but the result here
is that people for the first time in a
few hundred years have now achieved
freedom and are able to kind of go about
and do their own thing and so the ending
of this story is a little bit hokey you
know it's one of these things where it's
like neo it's kind of a montage sort of
situation and it's like no matter what
happens you know if anybody ever sends
out the call the Avengers will always
assemble you know there will always be
the Avengers and I don't like they're
waving at us the Avengers are waving to
us say hi everyone but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you